الطارش خطونا على حبوس عشان يخصو ويعمل
اوصنا اول شيء في فكره عامه مقبوله انه
انه الاعلام الغربي يورج عن العالم العربي
انه مجتمع كله متزمت كله متدين كله متطرف
كله مكبوت وهذا الشيء مش صحيح يعني في
بتحس تحسيهم عن جد في عطش عطش ل هالمواضيع
للكلمات وتحسم بشوف
بشوفوا حالهم بالموسيقى
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وبكلمات هو انه لما تقولي ابن الليل
ببيروت بالعميه فيها تاني بتقول بطريقه
تقريبا استهزائيه انه هذا ابن الليل بضله
سهران بضله سكران اللي هو بنفس الوقت
بالسياق تبع مدمون الاغاني في كمان ريفرنس
ل شي اسمه ليتس اللي هو ابن اللي
بالميثولوجيا الاغريقيه بالاغاني هذا هو
مبدئيا مضمون انه بناخذ قصص ميثولوجيا او
روائيه او يلي هو بنحطهم بالسياق تبع شو
عم بصير شو شو السياسه تبع السهر تبع
السهر شو شو الاجتماعيات تبع السهر ببيروت
وفي في كمان كان الفكره حتى بالفيجوال تبع
الالبوم انه نخلق ديانه مش ديانه شو ديانه
صغيره انه في اله جديد وفي مستمعين ه
الاله واللي بطبعو لي وهيدا اغانيه انه هو
هو اللي كتم هنا اغاني هد الديانه
[موسيقى]
الصغيره
ضحكت الفرحه
بقلب
[موسيقى]
بونغ هون ومسكني ق
الحال
بالعربي بحس انه يا اما بتقول
قصص تعتبر كانه اهانه يا اما في غموض على
الاشياء بتصير كثير غريبه وما فينا ما
عننا اللغه نحكي عن القصص
ي لحد معين مجتمعنا ما بيقبل انه ينحكى
عنه طبعا منه موضوع بس بينحط بالجنس بصير
اذا بدك
الحاد سياسه كل شي في لغه محرمه تقريبا في
كلمه قديمه كثير حلوه في كلمات بتلاقيها
بالقران ومش مستعمله بمحل ثاني حلوين بوا
30 شغله بكلمه
[موسيقى]
واحده
وحوا بالمحلات لما بحط مقاطع من اغاني
ثانيه بالاجمال بكونوا هدول مقاطع من يا
اما اغاني كثير مشهوره من ما يسمى العصر
الذهبي يعني يا اما اغاني او مقاطع شعر
كتبوها ناس كمان اثروا لالي بعتقد هذا
الشيء كثير مهم لانه خاصه كمنتجين ثقافيه
بالعالم العربي بنحس انه في هيدي التقديس
لقصص قديمه وكانه كانه للثقافه العربيه
دائما لازم تكون شيء عم نسترجع مش شيء عم
نخلقه بوقت في الناس اللي بتقدر تاخذ
قرارات مهمه اجمالا عم نحسم متحفظين اكثر
من الجمهور اللي بيجي بيحضر او بيسال عنا
وهيدا هي العالم اللي نحن بنشتغل فيه يعني
بتطلعي بلبنان خاصه
عندك البروتو تبع المغني اللبناني اللي
اخر شي بصير
مجاهد هذا واقع اوكي وتوتي المغنيه
اللبنانيه يلي بتطلع على التلفزيون
بتقوللك انا بشجع الرجال اللي بيضرب مرته
كيف نحن عايشين بهذا العالم
[موسيقى]
كيف
oh